[Music]
welcome back to science click today
wormholes according to the theory of
general relativity our universe is a
four-dimensional hyper surface in which
move about all objects this is
space-time space-time is not entirely
rigid it possesses a certain geometry
that might be distorted in the presence
of mass and energy it can bend it is
this curvature which is responsible for
gravitation a black hole is an object
whose mass is concentrated in a single
point which we call the singularity
because of their mass black holes
distort space-time around them very
close to the black hole space-time
becomes so distorted that all objects
and even light can no longer escape this
is the horizon of the black hole a
sphere inside which the curvature of
space-time is so great that it becomes
impossible to escape it to better
visualize a black hole we can represent
its geometry by doing what is called an
embedding in mathematics the embedding
will give us a geometric shape which
faithfully renders how space is curved
around the black hole after the mass we
see that space around a black hole
behaves essentially like a funnel at a
distance it is rather flat its Bend is
almost non-existent
however the closer we get to the horizon
of the black hole the greater the
gravitational pull surprisingly at first
glance we have the impression that the
very structure of the universe contains
a hole the existence of this hole might
seem strange we might wonder what would
happen if a spaceship arrived at its
edge does the universe stop at this hole
to answer this question it is necessary
to understand a certain mathematical
subtlety our universe possesses four
dimensions three dimensions of space and
one dimension of time by representing
the geometry of space we overlooked two
of these dimensions on one part the
horizon of the black hole is supposed to
be a sphere but here to be able to
represent the space-time we have
cancelled out one of the dimensions of
space the horizon comes to be a circle
furthermore we have only represented the
curvature of space not that of time we
have deliberately overlooked the
temporal dimension of our diagram
consequently the diagram is static it
represents the curvature of space at one
unique moment in time when it falls
towards the black hole
our spaceship moves forward in time
indeed if time did not flow and the
spaceship would remain motionless as
such when we look at the descent of the
spaceship as time progresses it is
necessary for our embedding to evolve as
well such that it remains representative
of the curvature of space-time at each
instant when we make our diagram evolve
in this way we realize that the hole
closes in on itself very quickly once it
reaches the horizon of the black hole
the spaceship keeps traveling through it
and continues its descent towards the
central singularity mathematically we
can show that regardless of the observer
and even for a ray of light this kind of
hole in the universe will always close
in on itself sufficiently fast for it to
be unreachable according to general
relativity the structure of space can
allow for such a hole but this hole must
ultimately close in on itself extremely
quickly such that it is impossible to
reach it
as such the universe does not really
possess any holes but from the point of
view of our imagination and from that of
mathematical elegance this is not very
satisfactory even if it closes in on
itself very quickly the hole does seem
to exist for a brief moment which seems
strange we get the impression that there
is something missing in our theory that
it does not perfectly describe the
situation with mathematics it is
possible to duplicate the geometry of
space inside our equations to make a
copy of it only in reverse in this
reversed version the copy of the black
hole behaves differently instead of not
being able to escape from its inside all
objects are on the contrary destined to
escape from it this is what we call a
white hole now that we find ourselves in
possession of this copy of space-time we
are able to stick it underneath our
original hole this mathematical move is
admittedly artificial and cannot be
readily backed up by any sort of
physical observation it is merely a
mathematical extension which is
motivated by the symmetry of equations
we form a structure which is much more
satisfactory with the shape of a tube
rather than the simple hole it is this
type of structure which we call a
wormhole if such a structure exists then
the wormhole must necessarily connect to
portions of space-time together
it might connect two independent
universes together but it is also likely
that it might connect to different parts
of one same universe in this way it
would form a geometric shortcut between
these two regions which light and
objects could use to travel quicker from
one place to another
giving free rein to our imaginations we
can quickly start to dream of a future
in which spaceships might go through
such shortcuts in space-time to travel
from galaxy to galaxy
however this wormhole which is made up
of a black hole in the white hole in
which we also call the Alan Rosen bridge
cannot be crossed as we have seen
previously its structure in the shape of
a tube closes in on itself extremely
quickly thus strangling any object as
adventures inside in this way it is
impossible to cross and all that can be
done is descend towards the singularity
of the black hole fortunately for our
curiosity there exist other geometries
for wormholes which are mathematically
valid under general relativity and whose
properties are more advantageous firstly
if a black hole rotates on itself or if
it possesses an electric charge then it
might be possible to cross the wormhole
associated to that black hole in this
case the central singularity is not a
fixed point but a ring which generates
rounded a new horizon through which it
might be possible to pass having said
that this wormhole would only be
crossable in one direction it would not
be possible to travel the other way
through the white hole theoretical
physicists have come up with more
sophisticated geometries with properties
that are more interesting and which go
beyond black holes and white holes to
allow for true travel through space-time
these wormholes are purely mathematical
and conceived to obey certain
feasibility conditions firstly we want
our wormhole to be crossable both ways
unlike the einstein-rosen bridge it must
be deprived of any sort of horizon so as
to make any point crossable
one way or the other
secondly the wormhole has to be stable
in time indeed if it closes in on itself
or if it is unstable it would be very
risky to travel through it thirdly to be
able to cross it smoothly the tube which
makes up the wormhole has to be
sufficiently wide otherwise it would
simply be impossible to fit in it
fourthly the time necessary to cross
that wormhole must be reasonable a few
years for example if the journey takes
billions of years the wormhole would be
of no great use finally the
gravitational forces generated by its
geometry must not be too strong so that
they do not damage or stretch the
structure of the spaceship traveling
through the wormhole mathematically
there exist such geometries which are
accepted by the theory of general
relativity one of the easiest examples
is the Morris thorne wormhole the Morris
Thorne wormhole possesses a number of
very interesting properties it has no
horizons no singularities and is
perfectly stable in time it will not
close in on itself while an object goes
through it
[Music]
this type of wormhole is particularly
interesting in that it is purely
geometric meaning that its structure
does not enable it to generate a
gravitational pull
as such it is possible to stay
motionless next to such a wormhole
without it either pulling us in or
repelling us when we might try to cross
it our spaceship will move along a
geodesic a straight line within the bend
of space-time the geodesic lines of the
Morris thorne wormhole are particularly
interesting
certain trajectories will enter the
wormhole go around in circles inside it
but end up coming out of the cheap from
the same end they entered to go through
this wormhole given that it does not
generates a gravitational pull to draw
things in it is necessary to orient the
spaceship precisely towards the center
of the hole at first glance just like
for a black hole light rays are deviated
by this geometry the wormhole acts like
a lens which distorts the image of
neighboring stars but since light race
can also go through we can also manage
to observe an image of the entities on
the other side of the wormhole
thus visualizing the part of the
universe with which it links up the
Morris Thorne wormhole is particularly
elegant and seems to meet all the
necessary conditions for the possibility
of intergalactic travel however it's not
that straightforward its existence
relies in fact on it being stable by
placing around a sphere of negative
energy this negative energy is necessary
to counter the tension of space-time
which continually forces structures of
this type to collapse on themselves as
we saw with the einstein-rosen bridge
unfortunately as per general relativity
we can show that such negative energy is
mathematically impossible which means
that stable wormholes cannot exist as
disappointing as this may seem wormholes
are thus impossible from the perspective
of general relativity because their
existence as stable structures depends
on the presence of negative energy over
a long period of time which is
mathematically impossible
this strong principle is called
topological censorship theorem it tells
us that any wormhole like structure will
censor itself automatically or in other
words close in on itself for any
observer attempting to reach it
but these definitive conclusions are
only based on general relativity
however we know very well that this
theory is not perfect it does not take
into account certain quantum phenomena
which occur at microscopic scales at
these scales other theories come into
play such as quantum field theory
according to this theory which describes
particles at a quantum scale vacuums
possess a certain energy which is
constantly agitated by fluctuations
these fluctuations are known as virtual
particles and we can liken them to
ordinary particles that would appear and
disappear extremely quickly all these
virtual particles generate a type of
residual pressure in space which in
certain configurations acts in identical
manner to negative energy this is known
as the Casimir effect as such even
though general relativity seems to
reject the possibility of stable
wormholes quantum phenomena could bring
a solution to the problem certain
scientists already imagined parallels
between wormholes in the phenomenon of
quantum entanglement
moreover certain more speculative
theories such as string theory for
example offer new perspectives to
conceptualize the existence of natural
wormholes which would have formed just
after the Big Bang and which would have
gotten stretched after their creation by
the expansion of the universe in string
theory such wormholes would be
stabilized by cosmic strings which have
announced they're purely hypothetical
objects finally if the existence of
wormholes could truly be proven it would
bring about the question of time travel
indeed the theory of relativity which
works not on space but on space-time
does not prevent such an object from
linking to different instants in time we
are still uncertain whether or not it
would be possible to travel into the
past but wormholes could make it
possible
having said that for coherence reasons a
wormhole would however never be able to
take travelers further back in the past
than the very moment of its creation
wormholes are objects that are
fascinating from a mathematical
perspective studying them remains very
speculative but nonetheless enables us
to reinforce our current theories by
constantly putting them up to the test
and by constantly trying to push back
their limits although the possibility of
crossable wormholes should not be
discarded entirely as for today the only
people crossing wormholes are
theoretical physicists with equations as
their spaceships
[Music]